c'est l'image du jour jean philippe
miller est marcellin nadeau bras dessus
bras dessous
les deux hommes préside le mouvement
pays à qui l'on créé après plus de six
mois des chances de commissions
d'ateliers le parti paya vient élargir
l'offre politique martiniquaise pour les
deux élus les erreurs et tout
rassemblement
il faut en finir avec les divisions
pourquoi mario nadeau j'ai dit pourquoi
pas
marcellin nadeau c'est un symbole très
fort c'est dire que quelque part on
arrête la guerre entre les fleurs entre
les besoins soient indépendantes c'est
surtout le ministre le symbole de
dimensionner qui refuse de voir en
priorité ce qui nous différencie et qui
décide de voir en priorité ce qui nous
réunit et nous rassemble les militants
de le peuple a après un débat
intéressant fructueux ont très
clairement décidé de choses la première
justement par cette jonction avec la
dynamique collective créée autour de
jean claude miller est bien de créer une
force politique nouvelle et en même
temps de maintenir nos peuples a comme
pôle d'animation politique autour de
valeurs que sont la citoyenneté
l'alimentation à soit-il l'écologie la
transformation sociale la souveraineté
une dizaine d'anciens membres d'unités
élus à l'assemblée de la ctm se retrouve
au sein de ce nouveau parti il n'est pas
question pour l'instant de partir en
guerre contre alfred marie-jeanne somme
fidèle aux principes qu'on a présenté
aujourd'hui tout ce qui va dans
l'intérêt de la martinique ou à notre
soutien
ce qui ne va pas dans l'intérêt
supérieur de la martinique des
martiniquaises et des martiniquais
n'aura pas notre soutien c'est aussi
simple que ça paye apporte déjà 150
adhérents le bureau du parti est entre
autres composé de nous et malouda
un ancien du palima deux gérantes
allemand si jérémy ferdinand du maudit
matinée est plat et enfin de rénine et
la conseillère exécutive à la ctm
ex-membre du mime deux personnes
manquent au tableau le maire de
rivière-pilote raymond théodose et celui
de cette marie bruneau nestor azérot